democrats using martin luther king jr
day to push their voting agenda and
attack republicans president biden
leaving the charge for his party and the
media by railing against the gop and
once again making claims about voter
suppression watch dr king wasn't just a
dreamer of that promise he was a doer
and on this federal holiday that honors
him
it's not just enough to praise him we
must commit to his unfinished work the
attack on our democracy is real abraham
lincoln george washington
thomas jefferson
all of them
with tears in their eyes
for the departure from our democracy
that is happening right now the
politicians are trying to cherry-pick
their voters
it is anti-democratic it is
anti-american
oh jesse waters i'm so glad we have
nancy pelosi to translate from legends
who have passed away about how they're
feeling right now in the afterlife yeah
i'm noticing a trend emily
and look what happened so the black vote
put joe biden over the top in the
primary last time
did joe biden deliver anything for black
americans in 2021 didn't get build back
better didn't get the election thing
didn't get anything on police reform
education health care got zip but the
minute the clock strikes 12 and it's a
midterm election year race card comes
down republicans are trying to subvert
their vote they're going to try to take
away your vote bull con or dixiecrat you
hear it all the time so what they do is
in the election year they play the race
card to excite the black base and then
when they're out of power and it's an
off year they do nothing for their most
loyal constituency i'm on to them and
everybody else should be
now i also read something he said joe
biden that the republicans plan to
subvert the election
and then crying chuck said they're
rigging the game and rigging the count
now i remember
when that kind of
direct assault
on the integrity of an election was
deemed censorable i mean you could never
say that you couldn't question the
integrity of our democratic institutions
how dare you
but the democrats are already saying the
votes rigged in the midterms and i don't
think the pinocchios have laid a hand on
either of those guys and here's another
piece of hypocrisy emily compagno
the democrats want to federalize the
state's
election laws right but democrat
governors want to fight tooth and nail
to regulate their own gun laws their own
state taxes the way their coveted
regulations are their own health care
policies but they want to take over the
state election powers which one is it
guys can't have both
that's right greg gutfall that happens
all the time the cherry-picking of these
rules the using of it when it when it
behooves them
exactly i can't get i can't do this
without saying it at least once uh we
know that just after saying that you
know filibustering for example right it
was antithetical to the entire bedrock
of this country and then 45 senators
used it to rail against uh sanctions
against the russian pipeline so to
jesse's point what's next greg
i don't know but i admire the fact that
you led this segment with scritty polity
a very very uh underrated band from the
80s
covered a whole breadth of styles but
can we publish a list of the people that
the dems think aren't racist and we can
put it on a post-it note on everyone's
fridge
because i have
if they could play this game and talk
about how the dead would think okay
you know i don't think martin luther
king would be as nearly as far left or
even close to far this left as the
current crop of democrat leaders i think
he would run screaming with that from
them because he was about character not
simply color he would hope that we've
moved on in the a block we talked about
exploding crime in b we talked about the
uh the plummeting democratic numbers all
this has one thing tied to it and that
is the obsession with race and falsely
and geraldo's talked about this falsely
framing election reform as a civil
rights struggle against bigots this race
card isn't just divisive for the
democrats it's energy draining you know
instead of helping all americans are
just pitting one group against the other
and that's not working we see right
through it kennedy
hi
um it's interesting because everyone has
a hot take here you know joy reid says
that whoever quoted martin luther king
who's a republican they just memorized
it in high school
she is incredibly divisive to the point
of being disharmonious you know if we
want harmony if we want a society that
works together uh then we we need to
stop listening to people like joy reid
she just flaps her clap trap and then
you have the other unjoyful joy behar
saying that it's republicans who are
creating these problems uh shoving
minority students into failing schools
and i will have her know that the worst
schools in the country are in
democrat-led cities where teachers
unions have an absolute stranglehold and
the fact that this
one-size-fits-all prussian factory
system is still employed where teachers
are unfireable and closed or schools are
unclosable and parents don't have a
choice that is explicitly racist
precious that geraldo top that
well i think that that people that
invoke the name of martin luther king
for a political bald-faced political
motive really are low
low brow
because you cannot invoke
that name and what he did and that
period for
a law that says you have to have a
voting id a voter id that every voter
has to have an id why is that
jim crow why is why is requiring or
requesting you to have a voter id to
prove who you are when you vote how is
that george wallace how is that
jefferson davis how's that strom thurman
you know it is really beyond the pale
and i you know i agree about the joy
reads of the world there is plenty of
room to disagree without
labeling being reduced to labeling your
opponent as a racist why why is that
racist what uh you know requiring a
voter id you know it's just like the
civil rights issue of our time is black
on black crime let me hear joy reid
speak about that once in a while and
then i'll i'll give her more slack
geraldo you said it was lowbrow but for
nancy pelosi it's very highbrow
and she knew thomas jefferson personally
so she actually she has some ground here
yes she did hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else